[Music]
while many around the world have been
anti-lockdown it's members of the
ultra-orthodox jewish community
that have been the most vocal in israel
clashes between the police and the
community
are an almost weekly occurrence so what
do they dislike
about the coronavirus restrictions this
is called a police takeover
it's a war against god and that's the
story
only certain parts of the community have
been anti-lockdown
but they still make up a large number of
the ultra-orthodox in israel
this honestly comes out of a mistrust of
the government
on a lot of issues um they mistrust the
government they believe the government
is quite
literally out to get them um some sort
of conspiracy to pry them away
from their religious lifestyle uh and
maintaining that religious lifestyle
they see it as their reson detroit
many have just been going about their
lives as if there's no pandemic
holding big weddings and even large
funerals for their beloved rabbis who
have died of the virus
but as those big events went ahead the
community became the
epicenter of the nation's coronavirus
outbreak
angering many israelis it's estimated
orthodox jews account for half of
israel's covert 19 hospitalizations
despite making up just 10 of the
population
to make matters worse it's almost
impossible for the community to keep
socially distanced due to their living
conditions
we're talking about generally poor in
large families
uh can be as many as 10 12 people living
in
in three four bedroom apartments in
crowded neighborhoods
a lot of them don't have internet a lot
of them might have
maybe one laptop so if we're talking
about
um you know having everybody at home all
of a sudden and people having to do zoom
school
these are things that their society is
just quite literally not built to do
so even if they want to comply with the
lockdowns or coveted protocols or
zoom schools their their society their
community their lifestyle
just doesn't support that kind of thing
health ministry data shows vaccination
rates in
ultra-orthodox areas lag far behind the
national average
but there appears to be growing support
for the vaccine
from rabbis this is one prick
for the person who's taking the vaccine
but a huge leap forwards for all of us
for humanity
it's bringing us closer to being able to
conduct normal lives again
and and now you can see that a lot of
them are actually lining up to get the
vaccine
so it's not that they're not taking
coven seriously
it's just that they truly and honestly
believe that maintaining their religious
and communal way of life
is quite literally a matter of life and
death and it's worth taking the risk for
cove